andré comte sponville bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté cet antre
est ce que vous pourriez pour ceux qui
ne connaîtraient pas vous présenter en
quelques mots et nous dire pourquoi nous
sommes ici aujourd'hui
écoutez nous sommes ici pour parler deux
fils aux effets du moins c'est ce que
j'espère quant à me présenter en
quelques mots d'abord je m'appelle andré
comte sponville j'ai 69 ans je suis père
de trois enfants qui sont grands en fort
heureusement ce sont de jeunes adultes
je vis en couple
pacsé
depuis 33 ans
et donc je suis philosophe et là il faut
en dire un petit peu plus quelle
philosophie j'ai coutume de dire que je
peux qualifier une position
philosophique en trois mots je suis
matérialiste rationaliste et humaniste
pour précéder un peu plus je dirais le
tube matérialiste au même sens les
piqûres
rationaliste au même sens que spinoza
enfin humaniste au même sens que mon
telle requête en tire un petit peu plus
pour que ça devienne intelligible en
quel sens c'est ce que depuis
matérialiste parce que l'eau dans le
langage courant un matérialiste au fond
si quelqu'un qui n'a pas d'idées au qui
ne vit que pour les plaisirs matériels
la bouffe le sexe le confort et tout ça
est tout-à-fait délectable mais
évidemment c'est pas en ce sens les
piqûres et matérialiste une piqûre il a
des idéaux et là spécialement un idéal
qui est la sagesse autres m'aviez être
matérialiste au sens philosophique du
terme ça n'est pas ne pas avoir d'idée
au c'est penser que tout ce qui existe
et matières ou produits de la matière
comme a dit être matérialiste et penser
qu'il n'existe rien dit mme matériel et
spécialement qu'il n'existe pas de dieu
immatériel needham ou d'esprit
immatériel romandie concrètement être
matérialiste c'est penser que ceux qui
pensent en moi ou en vous ça n'est pas
une âme un esprit immatériel c'est le
cerveau qui est bien sûr un organe aussi
matériel plus complexe mais aussi
matérielles que n'importe quel angle
c'est en ce sens que je suis
matérialisme je suis rationaliste au
même sens que spinoza disait être
rationalisée simplement penser que tout
est rationnel outre on dit que la raison
ambroix en théorie pourrait tout
comprendre en fait tout en pratique on y
avait bien sûr jamais tout à fait mais
être rationalise ça veut dire simplement
que l'irrationnel n'existe pas par
différence avec le déraisonnable qui
n'existe que trop bien phu évidemment
son comportement est déraisonnable si se
prend pour napoléon
ce n'est pas raisonnable mais sa folie
s'explique elle a des causes sapli n'est
pas raisonnable mais elle est rationnel
voilà donc je fus matérialise je pense
que tout est matière ou produits de la
matière je suis rationalise je pense que
tout et rational tout est rationnel part
dans tout est explicable au moins en
théorie par la raison je pense que
l'irrationnel n'existe pas enfin je suis
humaniste au même sens que mon thème
c'est à dire que pour moi l'humanise ne
ça ne consiste pas à célébrer
perpétuellement la grandeur de l'homme
des fois les gens me disent oui vous
êtes athée mais c'est pas grave parce
que vous croyez en l'homme non non je ne
crois pas à l'homme d'abord parce qu'il
ya pas lieu de croire en quelque chose
dont l'existence est avérée mais surtout
parce que ce qu'on sait de l'homme au
fond ce qui est plus souvent capable du
pire que du meilleur
heureusement plus souvent capable du
médiocre que du pire autrement dit être
humaniste à la façon de montaigne ça
n'est pas célébrée perpétuellement
d'autres grandes heures c'est au
contraire nous pardonner mutuellement
notre petitesse nos faiblesses nous nos
erreurs nous faut
et je crois que c'est ça l'humanisme
véritable tout appelle un humanisme de
la miséricorde ce n'est pas une religion
c'est une morale autrement dit l'homme
n'est pas notre dieu l'homme c'est notre
prochain mais cet humanisme de la
miséricorde nous pardonner mutuellement
nos faiblesses nos erreurs nos
petitesses c'est aussi un matérialisme
de l'exigence parce qu'au fond ce que
nous dit montaigne en une formule
souvent cité montaigne écrit il n'est
rien si beau et légitime que de faire
bien l'homme et du mans qu'est ce que
c'est que la morale basse et réaliser au
mieux notre humanité faire bien l'homme
faire bien la femme et du mans en
faisant quand ces serres notre devoir
voilà je suis matérialiste même sens les
piqûres rationaliste même sens que
spinoza humaniste au même sens que
montagne et puis nous d'inviter
d'ajouter un mot dans cette trop longue
présentation je me définis aussi souvent
comme actes et non dogmatique et fidèle
par là encore il faut expliquer chacun
de ces trois mots brièvement at elle
assez le plus simple je suis athée parce
que je ne crois en aucun dieu pourquoi
as tu es non dogmatique athéna
dogmatique parce que je reconnais
évidemment que mon athéisme n'est pas un
savoir simplement parce que personne ne
sait au vrai sens du verbe savoir si
dieu existe ou pas je dis dans mon livre
l'esprit de l'athéisme si vous
rencontrez quelqu'un qui vous dit je
sais que dieu n'existe pas ce n'est pas
d'abord à noter c'est d'abord un
imbécile
la vérité c'est qu'on ne sait pas et de
même s'il rencontrait quelqu'un qui vous
dit je sais que dieu existe c'est un
imbécile qui à la fois alors qu'il est
la fois c'est pas grave du tout mais qui
souhaite m'en prends sa foi pour un
savoir ce qui est une double erreur t-il
de fait puisque fois et savoirs sont
deux concepts différents et aux sites et
aux logiques puisque la fois en bonne
théologie chrétienne en tout cas la foi
est une grâce ce que le savoir nous ne
saurait peut-être voilà donc je suis
acte et je ne prends aucun dieu mais je
reconnais que mon athéisme n'est pas un
savoir c'est qu'une opinion une
conviction autrement dit je ne sais pas
si dieu existe ou non personne ne le
sait mais je crois qu'il n'existe pas
enfin halte hainaut dogmatique et fidèle
pourquoi fidèles parce que tout à fait
que je sois je reste attaché par toutes
les fibres de mon être un certain nombre
de valeurs morales culturelles
spirituelles qui sonné pour beaucoup
dans les grandes religions spécialement
dans les trois grands monothéismes pour
ce qui est de nos civilisations qui ont
été transmises pendant des siècles par
la religion spécialement par l'église
catholique pour notre pays mais non rien
ne prouve qu'elle ait besoin d'un dieu
pour subsister dont nous prouve au
contraire que nous nous avons besoin
d'elles besoin de ces valeurs pour
subsister une façon qui nous paraissent
humainement acceptable autrement dit ce
n'est pas parce que je suis athée que je
vais cracher sur deux mille ans de
civils un prêt qui règne sur trois mille
ans de civilisation judéo-chrétienne
hassani pas parce que tu date et que je
vais recul et de voir la grandeur morale
humaine du message des évangiles voilà
et donc avec ses 6 qualificatif voyez
matérialise rationaliste humanistes
athées non dogmatique et y dead est bien
en six mots pour avoir été un peu
l'impasse desquelles chacun des six mais
en six mots je peu à peu près me
présenter comme philosophe très bien bon
mais je pense que vous avez justement
bien fait de prendre le temps de cette
longue présentation parce que ç'a permis
de mettre le doigt sur la nécessité
aussi de définir les termes qu'on
emploie de très nombreux malentendus y
compris en philosophie proviennent de
désaccords sur des définitions qu'on ne
prend pas le temps d'expliciter or vous
l'avez fait et ça tombe très bien vous
me permettez une transition extrêmement
simple puisque vous êtes l'auteur d'un
dictionnaire philosophique
que vous actualisez que vous avez déjà
actualisé trois fois et vous avez
récemment publié la troisième édition de
votre dictionnaire philosophique donc
que je présente à l'écran et on peut se
rendre compte que c'est un volume
extrêmement épais
et justement la question je voulais vous
poser c'est sur la démarche qui est la
vôtre à travers ce dictionnaire
philosophique
le terme dictionnaire philosophique
évidemment est un hommage j'imagine en
tout cas à voltaire là son dictionnaire
philosophique et voltaire était le
représentant l'incarnation de l'esprit
des lumières dont l'une des ambitions
étaient la transmission des
connaissances la diffusion des savoirs
ou au plus grand nombre or il se trouve
que le premier obstacle que rencontrent
monsieur ou madame tout le monde au
niveau de la philosophie c'est la
question du vocabulaire c'est à dire il
ya du vocabulaire technique il ya pire
que ça il ya des mots de l' usage
courant qui prennent un autre sens et
vous en avez fait la démonstration tout
à l'heure lorsque vous avez parlé du
matérialisme la question je voudrais
vous poser ce m quelle est la démarche
qui est la vôtre à travers ce projet de
dictionnaire philosophique est ce qu'il
s'agit de prolonger le projet des
lumières de rendre accessible la
connaissance et la philosophie ou est
bien bien est-ce que c'est autre chose
qui vous a motivé
oui c'est bien de prolonger le projet
des lumières vous avez voltaire l'ennemi
comme sous titre des seigneurs style de
fille ou la raison par alphabet et la
raison parentale fabi tic dans son
propos il s'agissait le mot d'ordre de
voltaire écrasons l'infâme l'infâme pour
voltaire c'est l'intégrisme le fanatisme
l'obscurantisme à l'époque c'est
l'église catholique évidemment en france
du team siècle aujourd'hui il ya
d'autres intégrés il d'autres
fondamentalisme d'autres obscurantistes
qu'il importe de combattre aussi mais
c'est bien le même combat des
adversaires ont changé mais en effet
c'est toujours le combat pour les
lumières que diderot dont je suis plus
proche que de voltaire finalement
diderot avait un mot d'ordre hâtons nous
de rendre la philosophie populaire
hâtons nous de rendre la philosophie
populaire eh bien je crois en effet
qu'il ya urgence un rendrait plus de
films populaires pour combattre
l'obscurantisme
l'intégrisme le fanatisme mais il faut
dire aussi aux autres choses c'est que
j'ai repris ce titre de dictionnaire
philosophique
que j'appelle donc un voltaire par
différence avec ce que j'aurais pu
appeler un dictionnaire deux
philosophies comédiens dictionnaire
philosophique ça n'est pas la même chose
qu'un dictionnaire deux cibles de suite
pourquoi parce qu'un dictionnaire de
philosophie il a un style de fille pour
objet
mais qui lui reste en quelque chose
extérieure autrement dit un dictionnaire
deux fils de suie paradoxalement il n'a
pas lui-même deux philosophies nous
prenez le plus fameux des dictionnaires
de fil de fer français qu'on appelle la
lande qui me paraît au tout début du 20e
siècle si vous vous demandez quelle est
la philosophie du lalande il n'y a pas
si le défi du la langue puisque d'abord
il ya des dizaines d'auteurs qui ont
collaboré à ce volume ils n'ont pas tous
le nom là même qui le dit autrement
qu'un dictionnaire de philosophie il se
veut si logiquement neutre un personnel
est donc toujours passablement ennuyeux
et donc elle a des dizaines des
dictionnaires deux philosophies à la d
10 sur le marché comme andy dont
plusieurs sont excellents et qui se
ressemblent tous un peu alors que des
dictionnaires philosophique y en a pas
des dizaines il n'y en a que deux genève
le dictionnaire philosophique de
voltaire et si j'ose dire il y a le
mieux quelle différence y at-il entre
les fines herbes deux philosophies et
dictionnaire philosophique la différence
est qu'un dictionnaire philosophique il
n'a pas la ville de type pour objet qui
lui resterait extérieur hilale a fait
2-2 qui pour contenu qu'il veut par
définition intérieure et non pas l'ati
2e fille en général qui n'est qu'une
abstraction mais une philosophie en
particulier celle de l'auteur celle de
voltaire pour son dictionnaire
philosophique la mienne pour mon propre
dictionnaire philosophique c'est bien
que le paradoxe d'un dictionnaire
philosophique sexe d'un dictionnaire à
la première personne alors bien sûr je
définis tous les maux plus que voltaire
qui ne s'en souciait guère en vérité je
donne la définition mais après je dis ce
que je pense et du mot et de la chose
que le mot désigne quel usage
philosophie que j'en fait autrement dit
il s'agit de présenter ma philosophie
barbe alphabétique comme dirait voltaire
n'en prenant à chaque fois le le soin de
définir les mots que j'utilise sont là
des dictionnaires deux défis y en a des
dizaines des dictionnaires philosophie
qui en est que deux et qui ne ressemble
à aucun autre les dictionnaires du sud
deux fils se ressemblent tous plus ou
moins à des pionnières philosophique au
fond ne ressemble qu'à son auteur et
c'est le paradoxe de cette entreprise
c'est ça et c'est exactement ce sur quoi
j'allais rebondir à savoir que ce n'est
non seulement pas un dictionnaire qui
serait réservé aux personnes qui font
déjà de la philosophie mais ce n'est pas
non plus un dictionnaire qui est réservé
aux personnes qui voudraient seulement
s'initier à la philosophie par exemple
pour entamer des études c'est à dire que
vous définissez des termes aussi mme du
langage courant et vous inviter à une
réflexion philosophique sur ces termes
dans un langage qui est extrêmement
accessible et puis parfois aussi avec
des pointes d'humour d'ironie voire de
provocation alors je pourrais prendre un
petit exemple que j'ai bien aimé en
parcourant votre livre puisque c'est un
livre qui se parcourt davantage qu'ils
ne se lit c'est très agréable de pouvoir
l'ouvrir à n'importe quelle page et puis
de voir un petit peu les entrées et puis
par exemple pour le terme bonne qu'on
chanson voilà vous vous expliquer un
petit peu que c'est là la conviction
d'être du bon côté c'est de celui du
bien celui du vrai avec ce que cela
suppose d'ameublement et puis vous
concluez votre définition en disant
content de soi déçus des autres la
mauvaise conscience à tout prendre
vaudrait mieux et ça ça m'a amusé parce
que je crois que c'est l'une des
premières définition que j'ai lu dans
votre dictionnaire et je me suis dit
tiens il y a un parti pris philosophique
assumer et en même temps présenté de
telle sorte qu'il n'est pas perçu comme
comme agressif comme offensif est-ce que
vous pouvez essayer de décrire la
manière dont pour vous la philosophie
peut être liée à un engagement
un engagement personnel et pas
simplement la présentation des
philosophies qui existe
bah oui tu es bien c'est un lanceur
s'est plaint que je me disais de la
philosophie en général ça n'existe pas
aux années qu'une abstraction ce qui
existe ce sont des philosophies et il y
en a autant à la limite que deux
philosophes autrement dit la pub depuis
chacun doit avoir la sienne et s'il n'y
a pas une objection contre la
philosophie parce que souvent déserté
l'île au fond il ya autant de techniques
différentes qu'il ya deux philosophes
différents à quoi bon du coup stade là
que le film est justement c'est
précisément parce qu'il ya autant de fil
de faits différente qu'il ya de physique
différent que vous devez philosopher
vous même autrement dit comme je dis
souvent les philosophes ne sont pas les
femmes de ménage de l'esprit où les
hommes de ménage de l'esprit pourquoi
pourquoi en toi ton une femme de ménage
pour l'emploi une femme de ménage pour
ne pas faire le ménage soit même et bien
si vous croyez employés un videur lire
un philosophe pour n'avoir pas à fil de
faits vous même vous n'avez rien compris
à ce que la toux deux filles il n'ya
utilité à lire un philosophe au
contraire que pour mieux philosophe et
vous même et c'est ça la différence
entre les sciences et la philosophie
c'est que c'est justement parce que les
sciences font l'objet d'un savoir
objective
contrôlable bref qu'il n'y a pas autant
de physique différente qu'il ya de le
physicien différents que je n'ai aucune
raison de faire de la physique moi même
jusqu'à supposer je passe destinée à
faire de la physique je trouverais au
bout du compte le même résultat que
n'importe quel physicien compétents pl
j'aime mieux qu'il se charge du travail
je vais pas commencer à me demander
est-ce que e égal mc2 est ce que
l'énergie est vraiment égal au produit
de la masse par le carré de la vitesse
de la lumière puisque la démonstration a
déjà été fait par d'autres alors que
sais je me demande est ce que dieu
existe est ce que la vie a un sens
qu'est ce que le bonheur qu'est ce que
justice qu'est ce que la liberté et
c'est là je ne peux pas me dire que
d'autres ont fait le travail pour moi
puisque les autres ne sont pas d'accord
entre eux et donc je suis obligé de me
poser ces questions pour moi même et
c'est pour ça qu'il y a deux
philosophies au fond que singulière est
ce que j'ai voulu faire dans ce
dictionnaire philosophique c'est à fumer
cette singularité
jaillir de l'étude de style je dirais
plutôt cette singularité du film se fait
mais ce que disait quand on ne peut pas
apprendre la philosophie on ne peut
qu'apprendre à philosopher autrement dit
est commise et plus un peu plus tard
wildenstein la file de ti n'est pas une
doctrine mais une activité bien j'ai
voulu dans ce dictionnaire montrer la
façon dont moi je pratique cette
activité fille les attentes alors
faut-il ramos sur la forme vous aviez
commencé à le faire c'est un frigo
libyen 1400 pas je m'en excuse auprès
des lecteurs mais en même temps il ya un
peu plus de 2200 définition de 1200
entrées commandées pour les
dictionnaires ça veut dire que chaque
définition chaque article du
dictionnaire fait en moyenne une demi
page certains évoquent le plus qu on
fait une ligne une définition qui fait
une ligne les plus longs sont celles où
vit pas à juillet mais c'est d'exception
la plupart c'est demi page une page donc
c'est un fait grelier mais qui est
composée de très petit texte c'est pour
moi ça m'a pas parce que j'aime les
formes brèves au fond un dictionnaire
plus de filles c'est un peu un recueil
d'aphorismes et qui se donne la peine de
définir chaque mot et essayer de bâtir
une philosophie cohérente voilà donc
c'est un très gros livre m'est fait de
très petits textes et de la façon dont
ils obligent il m'a obligé à conjoindre
l'ampleur du travail puisque au fond il
ya trente ans de travail j'ai pas fais
que ça mais j'ai commencé ce design le
fic dans la première édition la 30 ans
était paru en 2001 mais j'y travaille
depuis une dizaine d'années il ya trente
ans de travail c'est un très gros livre
mais encore une fois ce sont des textes
très bref qu'on peut en effet parcourir
feuilleter lira choses et à gambades
comme dirait montagne même si j'ai reçu
une lettre d'un lecteur mais à propos
d'une édition précédente qui me disaient
j'ai écouté c'est formidable c'est la
première fois que je lis un dictionnaire
de la première à la dernière page parce
que il peut se consulter vous avez
raison c'est un dictionnaire mais en
même temps il peut se lire parce que
c'est aussi un essai c'est aussi
l'exposer une pensée personnelle en
l'occurrence évidemment la mienne et je
remarque d'ailleurs que quand vous vous
êtes définit en tant que philosophe vous
avez employé des termes qui sont liées à
des courants de pensée et non pas des
auteurs et j'ai remarqué qu'il y avait
aussi cette tendance chez certains
philosophes à se définir par référence à
un auteur alors on et épicurien alors on
n'est ni de chiens on est cartésien et
j'ai l'impression que votre démarche
allait justement de ne pas s'affilier à
un penseur comme si finalement le
penseur ne pouvait que réduire la pensée
comme si le fait de de ceux de
s'identifier à un individu s'était
c'était mettre des limites et mettre un
carcan à la pensée et dans votre
dictionnaire il n'y a que des noms
communs est ce que c'est un choix de
votre part de ne pas parler des auteurs
mais parler de leurs idées étant entendu
que si on parle des auteurs c'est
d'abord parce qu'ils ont exprimé des
idées
bon c'est vrai que j'ai relancé à mettre
les noms propres j'ai hésité 1 et bondit
de 5 mille quatre cents pages avec une
en commun s'il fallait en rajouter au
temps où à peu près autant avec les noms
propres avaient un autre lire que
peut-être c'est dieu fric auquel je ne
crois pas me prennent vie je penserai un
jour mais non là je me suis occupé des
idées plus que des auteurs mais aussi
pour une raison de fond c'est que depuis
que j'ai commencé à faire de la ville de
fille au lycée que la faculté j'étais
frappé par le fait que pour beaucoup la
file de filles étaient remplacés par
l'histoire de l'atv 2 c'est fini dire
qu'au lieu d'avoir une pensée
personnelle beaucoup de mes collègues
passent leur temps à commenter la pensée
des autres la pensée de philosophes dans
la plupart semin sont morts depuis des
années voire souvent depuis des siècles
les matches je voulais faire c'était pas
de l'histoire de la philosophie c'était
de la philosophie il a vu deux filles
vivant de la petite de deux filles pour
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas une raison pour
ne pas s'intéresser aux auteurs parce
que la seule façon d'apprendre at il le
fait c'est bien sûr de lire des grands
philosophes du passé vous savez malraux
disait c'est dans les musées qu'on
apprend à peindre
autrement dit celui qui veut devenir
artiste peintre doit d'abord aller dans
les musées pour voir les tableaux des
grands maîtres du passé pour les copier
les imiter pour enfin apprendre à
devenir le soi même eh bien je dirais de
même c'est dans les livres de
philosophie qu'on apprend ainsi que je
fais et c'est pourquoi quand je me
définis comme matérialise rationaliste
humaniste en même temps je dis à la
façon des coupures à l'attention de
spinoza la façon de montagne parce que
selon ses mots n'ont pas de sens si on
les coupe complètement du travail de la
tradition philosophique voilà donc whif
fille le voeu fait c'est penser par soi
même mais ça n'est pas pensé tout seul
parce que si on pense tout seul on pense
mal il faut d'abord apprendre à penser
et pour apprendre à penser il faut se
confronter l'engouement patiemment
sérieusement à la pensée des autres
notamment bien sûr d'abord des plus
grands philosophes du passé mais le but
ce n'est pas de passer ta vie a commenté
leurs oeuvres ça n'est pas de faire de
l'histoire de la vie de fille le but
c'est de philosopher soi même je
remarque quelque chose de très grec dans
votre manière de répondre à mes
questions et dans ma bouche c'est un
compliment c'est à dire il ya une sorte
d' équilibre et là par exemple
vous vous mettez bien l'avant cet
équilibre entre le penser par soi même
mais le s'appuyer sur ceux qui ont pensé
avant c'est dire que ce n'est pas du
tout incompatible en attendant sa part
aujourd'hui qu'il soit on pourrait
penser en faisant abstraction du passé
c'est à dire la table rase et on va
construire on va être l'auteur d'une
pensée que l'on considère comme étant
inédite alors que plus on avance plus on
s'aperçoit que c'est très difficile
d'avoir des idées nouvelles qui n'ont
pas été dites et puis a contrario il ya
ceux qui pensent qu' on ne peut pas
penser par soi même et que donc on est
condamné à la citation
ce que j'ai l'impression que vous mettez
en avant c'est le fait qu'on peut
s'appuyer sur des auteurs qui ont pensé
le monde avant nous qui ont des choses à
nous dire qu'ils peuvent entrer en
résonance avec ce que nous vivons
actuellement et en parlant de résonance
comment selon vous ce fait l'adhésion à
une pensée philosophique autrement dit
qu'est ce qui fait qu'on va être
sensible alors peut-être que j'ai depuis
la réponse en posant la question dans
ces termes qu'est ce qui fait qu'on va
être sensible à une pensée à un auteur
plutôt qu'à une autre qu'est ce qui fait
que telle philosophie va nous semblait
correspondre à la réalité du monde
massé le fait qu on y reconnaît ou qu'on
croit il reconnaître quelque chose de
son expérience parce qu'au fond personne
ne peut juger qu'à partir de sa propre
expérience et à sa philosophie est assez
curieux parce qu'il ya deux choses
différentes
il ya l'admiration et puis il ya le
sentiment de la vérité je prends un
exemple pour moi très particulier enfin
très éclairant ses leibniz qui est l'un
des plus grands philosophes de tous les
temps j'adore cet homme en plus l'homme
est sympathique mais c'est un génie
immense dans les sciences comme dans la
philosophie
c'est peut-être l'un d'eux mêmes sans
doute l'un des philosophes que j'admire
le plus et en même temps je n'y crois
pas du tout je pense que dans la pensée
de la ministre tout est faux c'est un
génie mais je lui reconnais pas le monde
telles que je les coûts tels que je
l'expérimentent si vous voulez alors
qu'elle avait à se prononcer mais
triptyque philosophe matérialiste
français du xviiie siècle qui n'est pas
du tout un génie a coûté de la limite ce
syrien sous les chauffe que quand je vis
la laiterie j'y reconnais le monde tel
que je l'expérimenté c'est bien que
j'aie plus d'admiration beaucoup plus
pour la limite que pour la mettrie et je
pense qu'au bout du compte la mettrie
est plus proche de la vérité que
limitera évidemment le mieux c'est quand
on admire des philosophes dont on pense
qu'ils sont plus près de la vérité alors
c'est le cas vis-à-vis des piqûres setca
vis-à-vis de de spinoza des philosophes
que ceux qui sont des génies immense
peut-être spécialement spinoza qui
peut-être l'un des plus grands
philosophes de tous les temps et en même
temps que dont je crois qu'il dit la
vérité mais pourquoi je le crois parce
que j'y reconnais ce que mon expérience
du monde de la vie m'a appris où se
donnent en expérience m'a convaincu et
c'est pour ça que ça reste subjectif
d'autres philosophes qui ont amplement
les mêmes qualités de même savoir que
moi vous diront qu à l inverse à nice
pour eux c'est la vérité espinosa pour
eux c'est un tissu d'erreur ce qui
l'empêchera pas d'admirer aussi spinoza
ce que je n'aime pas c'est les qui ne
peuvent admirer que ceux avec qui sont
d'accord ça c'est tout à fait au tout à
fait autre chose en en philosophie et
c'est pour ça que deux faits aussi une
école de tolérance on apprend à admirer
des gens avec qui on n'est pas d'accord
et bien cette admiration là elle est
aussi tonique c'est ça aussi qui nous
pose un article de ce fait alors
justement on va parler de socrate parce
que la phrase qu'on retient de socrate
tout ce que je sais c'est que je ne sais
rien une phrase qui est j'ai
l'impression souvent un peu mal
comprises
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que vous
avez une phrase qui est un petit peu
alors je veux pas dire votre slogan
parce que ce mois une connotation
publicitaire qui ne dérange un petit peu
ne phrase que vous aimez bien sa pensée
mieux pour vivre mieux or il y a une
idée parallèle qui court depuis
l'antiquité des piqûres à montaigne qui
est que la philosophie c'est
l'apprentissage de la mort donc quelque
chose qui n'est pas forcément très
réjouissant a priori la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser pour essayer
déjà de déblayer le terrain avant
d'entrer dans des tailles c'est en quoi
penser mieux aide à vivre mieux
vous avez raison ça ne va pas de soi 1
parce qu'au fond savait se disait
l'ecclésiaste plus de savoir plus de
douleur autrement dit on pourrait rêver
c'est ce qu'on appelle un imbécile
heureux de celui qui ne pense en aucune
vérité désagréable vivre et sa petite
vie tranquille
oui bien sûr sauf que c'est indigne de
l'humanité nous avons un esprit nous
avons une raison c'est pour les asservir
et par exemple il ya une vérité que vous
avez rappelé nous allons mourir je vais
mourir alors je pourrais tout faire pour
l'oublier l'imbécile heureux c'était de
celui qui ne pense jamais à la mort mais
ça veut dire qu'il est déconnecté de la
vérité ça veut dire qu'il vit dans
l'illusion dans le mensonge dans la
mauvaise foi alors que le philosophe
c'est celui qui voit enfin cette vérité
je vais mourir et qui essaye d'en tirer
un certain bonheur sibleyras et de l'âme
la grande leçon et celle de montaigne à
nouveau puisque monteil nous apprendre
il commente la phrase inspiré de platon
que philosopher c'est apprendre à mourir
mais pour la critique et aussitôt on dit
dans mon fils se fait en vérité ça sert
à apprendre à vivre mais puisque tout
devis et morten apprendre à vivre c'est
aussi apprendre à accepter la mort pas
du tout dans mon coin ce pas du tout
dans donne dans la mélancolie la
tristesse au contraire tirer de la
certitude de la mort des raisons
supplémentaires d'aimer la vie et c'est
ce qu'andré gide grand lecteur de
montaigne au xxème siècle résumera en
une formule dans les nourritures
terrestres angie dcri n'est pas assez
constante pensée de la mort n'a donné
pas assez de prix au plus petit instant
de ta vie
autrement dit si nous pensions plus
souvent que nous allons mourir nous
aimerions encore davantage la vie parce
qu'elle serait d'autant plus précieuse
que nous prenons conscience de sa
brièveté de sa finitude si nous passions
plus souvent que nous allons mourir
chaque instant serait vécu d'autant plus
intensément qu'il se détacherait comme
dit encore là comme t-il encore en
régime sur le fond très obscur de la
mort est donc cette façon de voir la
vérité en face oui nous allons mourir
montagne écrite ou contentement des
mortels et mortelle dont il amorce fait
partie de la vie et si tu veux aimer la
vie pas forcément faut accepter la mort
si tu te dis j'aime à bien la vie s'il
n'est pas l'amour tu n'aimes pas la vie
puisqu'il ya la mort effective et tonte
ou le geste fils de fixer de voir la
vérité en face oui c'est vrai je vais
mourir et d'essayer si on est capable
d'en tirer un certain bonheur d'en tirer
des raisons supplémentaires d'aimer la
vie et d'aimer la vérité alors c'est
pourquoi je dis souvent que mieux vaut
une vraie tristesse qu'une fausse joie
quand je dis mieux vaut une vraie
tristesse qu'une fausse joie ça veut
dire que si le philosophe a à choisir
entre une vérité est un bonheur il n'est
philosophes ou digne de l'être qu'à
condition de choisir la vérité notamment
ne faisait pas de penser ce qui me fait
plaisir il s'agit pas de penser ce qui
me rassure ceux qui meurent un revenant
il s'agit de penser ce qui me paraît
vrai autrement dit pour le philosophe
l'exigence de vérité la quête de vérité
dans l'incertitude dans le doute la
quête de vérité doit l'emporter sur la
quête du bonheur sinon c'est plus de la
philosophie c'est de la méthode coué
mais une fois qu'on est dans ce chemin
vers la vérité évidemment l'enjeu reste
le nous toute humanité de tout être
humain essayer d'en tirer un certain
bonheur une certaine joie une certaine
satisfaction voilà il s'agit de vivre
heureux au web la firme tout le monde et
d'europe mais le pari du philosophe
c'est d'essayer de vivre heureux dans la
vérité ils ont dans le peu de vérité
auquel nous avons accès même devancé à
autant de vérité assez de vérité malgré
tout pour faire la différence clairement
entre un savant et en ignorant entre la
lucidité et ville religion d'autant que
considérer que la vérité serait
forcément synonyme de malheur est ce que
ce n'est pas le point de vue de celui
qui n'est pas encore dans la vérité
c'est-à-dire qu'il a qu'il envisage de
son point de vue d'ignorants y aura
entre guillemets je m'explique on entend
souvent dire que plus on ait conscience
de la réalité du monde et plus on va
être enclin aux malheurs
c'est une espèce de version mal digéré
de schopenhauer qui consiste à dire
quand on voit tous les malheurs du monde
on ne peut pas être heureux mais
finalement est-ce que la quête du
philosophe qui est la quête de la vérité
ou en tout cas de la compréhension du
monde est ce que cette compréhension
n'est pas elle-même en soi vectrice de
bonheur est-ce que accéder à la
compréhension d'un phénomène même si ce
phénomène extérieurement est synonyme de
souffrance est-ce que la compréhension
de ce phénomène n'est pas synonyme de
sinon de bonheur du moins de
satisfaction de joie ça reprend l'idée
de la joie chez spinoza qui est la
compréhension des causes qui nous
déterminent
oui bien sûr toute connaissance est un
plaisir parce que nous avons un désir de
connaissance un désir de vérité et même
quand la vérité en l'occurrence et ta
mère il ya une joie un âne à connaître
et j'en suis tout à fait d'accord alors
qu'à l'inversé c'est le relais sur quoi
je voulais revenir
ce qui donne tort à l'imbécile heureux
et ce qui fait qu'à plupart des
imbéciles ne sont pas c'est que ils
vivent dans l'illusion et que le réel ne
cesse de les décevoir au fond c'est
pourquoi j'ai beaucoup travaillé dans
mes premiers livres sur l'idée de taper
un gay désespoir par le désespoir du
suicidaire ou du d'être imminent leduc
est désespoir de celui qui n'a plus rien
à espérer parce que au fond le réel me
sifflent les choses telles qu'elles sont
et qui te donnes moi yable transforme
éventuellement lui plaisent davantage
que ses rêves ou que ses illusions alors
qu'un inverse celui qui vit dans
l'espoir est donc dans la crainte
lorsque me dit spinoza il n'y a pas
d'espoir sans crainte ni de crainte sans
espoir celui qui vit dans l'espoir vit
donc dans la crainte et donc il n'est
pas gros mais qui plus est le plus
souvent évidemment le réel va venir le
décevoir alors c'est ce que j'expliquais
dans mes premiers vivre l'une des
premières lettres de lecteurs que j'ai
reçus d'entités à trentaine d'années
mais tu as écrite par un psychanalyste
je ne connaissais pas qui m'expliquait
qu'il était d'accord avec mon livre qui
était le traité du désespoir et de la
béatitude parce que me disait-il
dans mon expérience de psychanalyste je
constate que l'espérance est la
principale cause de suicide on ne se tue
que par déception aussi s'est il y la
formule m'avait frappé d'autant plus que
ma mère s'est en effet suicidé j'étais
adulte j'avais une trentaine d'années il
repense en assam je dis bah voilà ah oui
maman s'est tuée par déception elle
s'est fait parce que depuis des
décennies la vie ne correspondait pas
aux espoirs qu'elle s'en était fait et
bien fait vous dire la vie ne correspond
jamais aux espoirs que nous nous en
faisons ti l'extérieur on nous apprend
quelque chose de clair c'est bien ça
sauf que pour beaucoup de gens quand la
vie ne correspond pas à leurs espoirs
quand ils sont déçus ils ont conclu que
c'est la vie qui a tort qu'est ce que ça
peut vouloir dire que la vie à tort la
vie elle fait ce qu'elle peut maman
d'idées au contraire cible quand la vie
ne correspond pas à nos espérances
approuve pas c'est la vie qui a tort ça
prouve que c'est nos espérances qui dès
le départ était illusoire infondées et
donc comme je les y ai souvent il s'agit
d' espérer un peu moins et de connaître
d'agir et des mets un peu plus
espérer un peu moins parce qu'au fond
quelle différence y at-il entre les
sports et la connaissance et qu'on
espère que ce qui n'est pas rien on peut
connaître que ce qui est un pareil pour
l'amour on espère que ce qui n'est pas
on ne peut aimer que ce qui est et
pourquoi l'action partie comme disent
les stoïciens mieux vaut faire ce qui
dépend de soi plus tôt qu'espéré
perpétuellement et donc craindre ce qui
ne dépend pas et c'est pourquoi je
disais j'anticipe sur la suite de
nouveaux échanges mais que le sage est
un homme d'action parce que là où
beaucoup de gens passent leur vie à
espérer ce si cela est donc à craindre
ceux là où ceux ci n'y a pas d'espoir
sans crainte ni de crainte sans espoir
bref là où beaucoup de gens vivent dans
l'espoir est donc dans la crainte dans
la peur lesage préfère lui faire ce qui
dépend de lui il désirait ce qui est
plutôt que ce qui n'est pas aimer et
faire ce qui dépend de lui agir encore
une fois il s'agit d' espérer un peu
moins donc de craindre un peu 1 et de
connaître d'agir et des nez un peu plus
ça alors ça c'est une idée je vous
remercie d'insister là dessus parce que
les gens qui suivent ma chaîne savent à
quel point je promeut le stoïcisme et
l'une de ses maximes qui dit
lorsque tu auras des a pris à espérer je
t'apprendrai à vouloir et on peut on
peut tourner ça dans tous les sens on
peut spéculer on peut raisonner on peut
on peut faire tout ce qu'on voudra il
n'empêche que cette phrase elle est
imparable dans le sens où
vouloir c'est se donner les moyens
d'agir conformément à nos moyens
conformément à nos capacités espérer
c'est imaginer que quelque chose qui
n'est pas là et qui peut être n'a aucune
chance de se produire se produisent donc
c'est vivre dans l'illusion et c'est
ensuite se plaindre lorsque le réel ne
répond pas à nos illusions vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure la vie ne se trompe
pas le réel ne se trompe pas et vous
l'avez précisé en introduction vous êtes
rationaliste vous considérez que le réel
et rationnelle autrement dit que en
théorie en droit tout est explicable et
je suis absolument d'accord je vois
difficilement d'ailleurs comment
pourrais réfuté cette affirmation
selon vous quelle est la cause de ce
refus
delà de la pensée spéciale quelle est la
cause de cette nécessité de se complaire
dans la souffrance et l'idée que le
monde est injuste
d'abord sur le stoïcisme
qui est une très grande pensée j'en suis
d'accord mais je ne me dis je n'irai pas
non plus comme stoïciens pourquoi parce
que dans le space vient volontariste fil
de type d'action mais il ya aussi un
fatalisme philosophie du destin
notamment d'une nécessité un peu à la
façon de spinoza mais d'une providence
puisque pour les stoïciens le monde des
dieux le stoïcisme est un panthéisme
mais au fond c'est ce qui m'interdit
d'être d'être d'être storyciens
alors pour pau pour le reste ah oui la
fameuse formule que vous citez quand tu
auras des esprits quand tu auras
désappris à espérer je t'apprendrai à
vouloir
écouter va je suis un peu embarrassée
parce que c'est une formule que j'ai
souvent cité et dont je finis par
crainte qu'elle ne soit de moi parce que
quand je veux retrouver la référence je
vais sur google comme tout le monde il
ya quinze occurrence de cette formule
mais qui tout renvoie un ami texte et
donc je finis par me dire que c'est pas
une citation de sénèque serait comme je
croyais que c'était bien résumé par mois
de la france étaient d'accord sur le
fond je n'ai rien inventé effectivement
sénèque le pende bien ceci mais je
précise ça pour les historiens de la
fille de ce film à venir je crains en
fait la vérité que quand j'ai cité cette
formule en attribuant un moi-même à
sénèque géant vérité n'ont pas cité
sénèque mais résumer la pensée de
sayabec mais quant au fond il a raison
bien sûr il s'agit de désapprendre à
espérer au dessus plus modestes espérer
un peu moins comme zep ce que désapprend
resté un peu par cécile d'espérer
pourquoi mais parce qu'il n'ya pas de
crainte sans espoir comme tous homme
plein de peur plein de crainte nous
sommes morts de trouille donc forcément
on espère les des tas de choses donc
s'agit pas de désapprendre espérait il
s'agit d' espérer un peu moins mais en
revanche effectivement il s'agit
d'apprendre à vouloir et donc agir parce
que attention il n'y a pas de volonté
sans action 1
on peut désirer sans agir on peut
espérer et sans plaisir on ne peut pas
vouloir s'engager autant m'aviez c'est
le secret du stoïcisme son coeur vivant
tu fais toujours ce que tu veux pas
toujours ce que tu désires mais tu fais
toujours ce que tu veux mais attention
tu ne fais que ce que tu veux et donc
apprendre à vouloir c'est par définition
à prendre agir une volonté qui n'agit
pas ça n'est pas une volonté c'est un
projet c'est un rêve c'est qu'une
intention ça n'est pas une volonté il
n'ya de volonté qu'un acte vouloir c'est
agir ou ce n'est pas vouloir et c'est
pourquoi le volontarisme stoïciens qui
nous apprend à vouloir est une
philosophie une éthique de l'action
alors à ce propos
je voulais vous poser la question sur la
différence entre le sage et le
philosophe pourquoi je dis souvent à mes
abonnés qui ne faut pas confondre le
philosophe et le sage pour résumer un
objet de schématiser je dirais que le
philosophe c'est l'apprenti sage celui
qui tend vers la sagesse et peut-être
cette quête est elle perdue d'avancé
peut-être n'y arriveras ton pas mais
l'image que j'associe à ces deux à ces
deux catégories c'est que le philosophe
il est encore dans l'action il est
encore dans le désir le désir de la
connaissance
là où le sage
il serait parvenu et donc ils ne
seraient plus troublé par son désir pour
rester dans l'eau qu'à billère stoïcien
or j'ai lu et entendu de votre part que
vous disiez que le sage donc celui qui
est qui a atteint la connaissance est
aussi un homme d'action donc pour vous
porter un petit peu la contradiction
mais en fait c'est surtout un prétexte
pour vous permettre d'éclairer de
développer ça en quoi le sage selon vous
est il un homme d'action
alors que sont l'âge de la sagesse et de
la fille de fait vous avez raison le
philosophe c'est l'écolier le sage celui
qu obtenu son diplôme si je dire la
chose en
plaisantant c'est donc dans la même
chose pourquoi parce que la philosophie
est un certain travail travail de la
pensée néo travail la sagesse serait
plutôt un certain repos l'article de die
ça se fait avec des mots par des
discours et des raisonnements comme des
piqûres la sagesse serait plutôt une
certaine qualité de de silence et donc
la philosophie c'est l'amour de la
sagesse taquet de la sagesse et bien sûr
la sagesse vaut mieux que que la fille
de phil ochs passer notre vie à
discourir a arraisonné
l'essentiel de la vie doit se vivre
dedans dans le silence pas forcément par
son fond c'est de parler mais dans une
espèce de silence intérieur qui est
simplement l'amour de la vie la vraie
sagesse et celle de montaigne résume en
une phrase à la fin des essais pour moi
donc j'aime la vie et c'est ce vers quoi
il faut tendre sauf que disait justement
montaigne m'a guéri d'une certaine
conception trop enthousiaste de la
sagesse
parce que par exemple quand j'ai vu
epicure le 10 18 ans ça m'a enthousiasmé
ce programme de sagesse à la fin de la
lettre à ménécée qui est donc le petit
traité de sagesse épicurienne 5,6 passes
géniales que s'invite tout nos
spectateurs à lire à la fin de la lettre
à ménécée epicure écrit exactement ceci
idées à son disciple mais n'essaient me
dit mais le son jour et nuit et puis ne
fera jamais troublé ni à l'état de
veille ni en songe mais que vivra comme
un lieu parmi les hommes car il ne
ressemble en rien un être mortelle celui
qui vit parmi des biens immortel moi je
disais ça à 18 ans ça m'a bouleversé je
dirais presque que ça met un peu monté à
la tête lewis avait 18 ans mais j'en ai
bientôt 70 ans vous disait aujourd'hui
écoutés je ne suis jamais troublé mais
je vis comme un vieux parmi les hommes
vous diriez l'économie il a pété des
plans et bien alors cette sagesse
épicurienne ses skis piqûre appel en
grec ataraxia l'ataraxie on pourrait
traduire par sérénité mais littéralement
le a et privatif ataraxia ça veut dire
absent de trous et bien le contraire de
cette ataraxie piqûre yens c est une
phrase de montaigne et que j'ai dû bien
après avoir les piqûres et qui est une
récusation de la traque ces piqûres yens
une phrase dont j'ai fait deux types
d'un mini mais surtout une espèce de
mantra monteyne écrit lumineusement ces
choses tendre que la vie est aisé à
troubler ses shoes tendre que la vie est
aisé à trouver tant vos sens où on parle
d'un bois temps d'une pierre temps de
centre la fragilité une pierre un bois
facile à briser à plessé ben voilà c'est
chose tendre que la vie est aisé à
troubler autrement dit mon cher epicure
pourrait dire rester que deux montagnes
qui adore répit que des manches et
articule pourrait-il lui dira t'on
ataraxie c'est sympa ça fait rêver les
adolescents mais ça ne marche pas parce
que ces choses tendre que la vie est
aisé à trouver autrement dit montagne
aussi d'expérience de la vie m'ont
libéré de cette conception trop
dogmatique troupe enthousiaste de la
sagesse non pas que j'ai renoncé à toute
sagesse mais parce que mon times a été à
penser une autre sagesse ce que
j'appelle ça gèle peu ce qu'on vend une
sagesse à quarantaine automatique
sagesse pour ceux qui ne sont pas des
sages au sens où les piqûres ou spinoza
pouvait l'être ou prêtant des lettres
une sagesse pour ceux qui ne sont pas
des sages qui n'envisage même pas bleue
de venir mais qui ont la sagesse au
moins de l'accepter et bien cette
sagesse de second rang c'est la sagesse
de montaigne et aux fontaines hadjez
pour ceux qui ne sont pas des sages
c'est la seule qui importe c'est la
sagesse pour vous c'est la 7 à 13 pour
moi puisque comme je lé souvent écrit la
sagesse n'existe pas il n'y a que des
sages et ils sont tous différents et
aucun bien sûr ne croit à la sagesse
aucun je suis patiente a peut-être les
piqûres et pizzas y croyait mais en tout
cas mon thème m'a libéré de cette
croyance là les quantités pour moi donc
j'aime la vie ibid essentiel parce que
la sagesse la vraie sagesse pour moi ça
n'est pas l'amour du bonheur pas besoin
d'être un sage pour rémy le bonheur
n'importe quel imbécile est capable
d'aimer le bonheur la vraie sagesse ça
n'est même pas l'amour de la sagesse ça
c'est la philosophie pas besoin d'être
un sage pour aimer la sagesse il suffit
d'être philosophe filosofia c'est
l'amour de la sagesse sauf que la vraie
sagesse pour moi ça n'est pas l'amour du
bonheur ce n'est pas l'amour de la
sagesse la vraie sagesse c'est l'amour
de la vie heureuse ou malheureuse sage
ou pas et bien sûr aucune vide et
heureuse ou sage en son entier et c'est
pour ça que montaigne est pour moi le
plus sage des philosophes parce qu'il
est celui qui justement ne croit pas en
la sagesse en tout cas à part cette
sagesse absolu et nous apprend à aimer
la vie plus que la sagesse pour terminer
cet entretien audrey j'aimerais tenter
une synthèse entre ce qui va sembler
être deux notions qui nous ont
accompagnés durant cet entretien
si on admet que nous sommes tous mortels
que nous devons l'accepter même si nous
ne l'approuvons pas et que
la connaissance rend heureux ou rend
joyeux il ya finalement est-ce que la
transmission
ne serait pas pour nous le meilleur
moyen de se rendre immortel
surtout pas d'abord n'avait aucune
chance de réussir nous sommes mortels l
atlantide accepté lors mieux vaut croire
en la résurrection
mais si vous êtes croyant quelques
religions que ce soit
plutôt que croire qu'on va se rendre
immortel par la fastienne vous pouvez
transmettre tout ce que vous voulez à
vos enfants vous aider les enfants à vos
élèves vous n'en mourrez pas main et
donc le vu ça n'est pas du tout de se
rendre immortel c'est de permettre que
la vie continue que vos enfants vont
continuer à vivre et d'une façon humaine
que l'humanité va continuer à vivre et
de façon mais est donc le problème de la
transmission c'est pas vous c'est les
gens à qui vous transmettez vous pouvez
transmettre tout ce que vous voudrez
vous n'en mourrez pas moins mais la vie
de vos enfants la vie de vos élèves la
vie des générations à venir on sera un
peu meilleur on a et donc la
transmission avec une valeur essentielle
moi j'aime beaucoup cette formule que ma
vie à mes amis juifs mais qui n'avait
pas inventé il me disait on est toujours
qu'un juif c'est pas quelqu'un dont les
parents sont juifs c'est quelqu'un dont
des enfants sont suivis autrement dit le
vous réjouir en ce sens la kippa ou pas
en dieu c'est celui qui a su transmettre
à ses enfants ce qu'il a reçu certain
sens de la communauté de la tradition de
la torah et c'est bien moi qui ne suis
pas juive qui ne fuit plus chrétien mais
j'ai envie de dire ben voilà le
véritable humaniste c'est pas celui dont
les parents sont humanistes à faire
tromper a été fort peu le véritable
humaniste et celui dont les enfants sont
humanistes il s'agit de transmettre ce
que nous avons reçues et donc la
transmission est l'équivalent en
benjamins de ce qu'on appelle la
fidélité vers l'amont il s'agit pas
d'inventer nouvelles valeurs il s'agit
d'inventer ou de réinventer une nouvelle
fidélité aux valeurs le plus souvent
fortes ancien que nous avons reçue est
que dans tout ça vaut à charles
transmettre parce que la seule façon d
vraiment fidèle à ce qu'on a reçu c'est
évidemment de le transmettre et donc oui
la transmission est quelque chose
d'essentiel
mais qui concerne la vie de nos enfants
de nous sans dents ça ne l'empêchera pas
de mourir mais c'est pas grave parce
qu'un versement mourir n'empêchera pas
que nous ayons vécu ce que nous avons
vécu et donc ce que nous vivons en ce
moment que nous aurons vite oublié mais
en quelque chose c'est une vérité
éternelle dans 100 ans dans dix mille
ans plus personne bien sûr ne se
souviendra de cet entretien il ne serait
pas que nous n'en sera pas moins vrai
que vous et moi en ce moment nous sommes
en train de parler de philosophie
autrement dit comme je dis souvent
l'éternité c'est maintenant s'agit pas
d'attendre une autre vie d'espérer de
brebis dit je ne sais quel immortalité
il s'agit de comprendre pour le lieu
dans le langage que mon christianisme
dantin que nous sommes déjà dans le
royaume l'éternité c'est maintenant
[Musique]